[Musique]
Avec celle-là, ça m'en fait trois. Une
fois que j'aurai les sep boules de
cristal, je pourrais faire apparaître le
dragon pour qu'il exauce mon vœux.
Enfin, ça je le savais déjà mais fallait
que je le répète à voix haute sans
aucune raison.
[Musique]
Bonjour 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Salut à tous, vous l'attendiez.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler de Dragon
Ball. Non, pas Dragon Ball Z, juste
Dragon Ball. J'adore Dragon Ball Z et il
y a pas de problème. Mais au vu des
derniers trucs, je pense que Toriama est
mort et qu'on lui prélève de l'ADN pour
continuer la série. Salut, je suis ton
frère que tu as jamais vu. Salut, je
suis ta sœur que tu as jamais vu. Salut,
je suis une petite merde. La plupart
d'entre vous connaissent évidemment
Dragon Ball Z parce que ce truc a été
rediffusé des milliards de fois mais une
petite partie d'entre vous, il y en a
parmi les plus jeunes ne connaissent pas
Dragon Ball tout court. En même temps,
j'ai pas souvenir que cette série a été
beaucoup rediffusée. Pour résumer Dragon
Ball sorti en 84, un manga puis adapté
en dessin animé et donc une série qui
raconte la jeunesse de sang Goku, son
entraînement avec Tortue génial, sa
rencontre avec Krilin et introduit tous
les premiers personnages de la série he
Piccolo, Yamchat, Enchinan et cetera.
Bref, si vous n'avez pas vu cette série,
je vous la conseille évidemment et que
ce soit en manga ou en animé, elle est
juste excellente et d'ailleurs par
certains côtés, je dirais même qu'elle
est mieux que Dragon Ball Z. D'ailleurs,
paradoxalement, même si DBZ est beaucoup
plus connu du grand public, il n'a pas
été adapté en film. Et dire, je
comprends pourquoi parce que DBZ avec
des vrais acteurs, c'est définitif, ça
ne marche pas. Par contre Dragon Ball
lui, il a été plusieurs fois. On y
trouve notamment Dragon Ball Fight S
Goku Win S Goku, un film coréen. Dragon
Ball The Magic Begins, un Taiwano
Philippin. Et évidemment Dragon Ball
évolution, un américain. Alors, est-ce
que ces films sont mauvais ? Ben,
évidemment, oui, parce que sinon j'en
parlerai pas. Mais à quel point sont-ils
mauvais ? Et bien, on va voir ça tout de
suite. Donc l'histoire commence dans un
pays qui n'est clairement ni la Chine ni
le Japon he les villageois se réunissent
parce qu'aujourd'hui la boule doit être
transmise au nouveaux chef. Mais
soudainement des vaisseaux de Space
Invaders attaquent. Et [ __ ] Michael B
c'est une petite merde à côté de ce
film. Non parce que après que le chef du
village décide d'aller cacher la boule
s'ensuit une scène qui dure vraiment
probablement 5 minutes en temps réel
nonstop de maison qui explosent et de
gens qui courent. Et puis même comment
ils marchent ces bâtiments d'ailleurs ?
Parce que visiblement n'importe quel
projectile les fait exploser. Arrêtez
d'exploser votre budget dans la brique.
Moi, j'ai choisi les pains de C4 comme
isolation et je peux vous dire que c'est
du solide,
le C4. Allez, un de C4. Bref, donc les
méchants qui arrivent tout droit d'un
clip des années 80 arrivent devant le
temple. Et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
tu étais pas censé planquer la boule toi
? Oh [ __ ] c'était ça le chef des
méchants qui s'appelle le roi cornu qui
n'est ni Pilaf, ni Piccolo, ni personne
en fait, veut s'en emparer, mais les
moindres du village le protègent en
faisant un bouclier humain. Ouais, je
suis sûr que ça va marcher he vu que
juste avant on l'a vu détruire tout le
village mais non, étonnamment ça ne
marche pas et le méchant s'en en parle.
Il y a sur cette terre sep boules de
cristal
magique. J'ai déjà réussi à en retrouver
deux. Mais ça vous le savez déjà,
n'est-ce pas ? J'avais juste envie de le
répéter à moi tout seul comme ça.
Lorsque j'aurai réuni toutes ces boules
magiques, je ferai apparaître le grand
dragon sacré au milieu de la voûte
céleste et il exaucera mon vœu. Avoir un
meilleurque.
On retrouve donc Sang Goku et Sangohan
qui ne s'appelle pas Sangohan d'ailleurs
mais Sparkle dans leur maison. Je ne
laisserai jamais personne te faire du
mal et je prendrai soin de ton trésor.
Tu sais, tu sais, grand-père, grâce à
cette super baguette magique, je
pourrais te protéger toi et ton trésor,
de tous les envahisseurs. Mais ça, tu le
sais déjà, n'est-ce pas ? Vu c'est toi
qui me l'a donné. J'avais juste envie de
le répéter sans raison, en fait. On
retrouve donc Goku et Sparkle qui
s'entraînent et ça nous permet
évidemment de redécouvrir toutes les
techniques du manga qu'on connaît déjà.
Ah non, ça je connaissais pas. Ça non
plus. Ça non plus. OK. Et finalement, il
finit l'affrontement
sur de crème. Un pot de crème. Un sac de
riz. Un sac de riz. Un plat de pâte. Un
rap cin un pot de crème. Un pot de
crème. J'ai bien peur que tu es perdu.
Donc c'est toi qui va préparer le repas
de midi.
Seb Non, le pot de crème est plus fort
que le sac de riz. Il a gagné. Il a
gagné. Du coup, vu que Sang Goku a
perdu, il par chasser près d'une
cascade, hein, comme dans le manga, et
tombe sur Bulma dans sa voiture qui ne
s'appelle pas Bulma et qui cherche les
Dragon Ball avec son radar. Attention
après leur rencontre sans Goku et Bulma,
attendez une minute.
[Musique]
Attention, elle a totalement essayé de
l'écraser là. C'est quoi ce monstre ? Il
est effrayant le monstre, c'est toi pour
qui tu te prends pour aussi arrêter ma
voiture ? Pourquoi tu t'es pas laissé
écraser sale pauvre ? Goku est sitoué
donc c'est le nom de Bulma font
connaissance et Goku évidemment est
gentil avec elle parce que malgré ces
deux tentatives de meurtre ben c'est une
fille et il faut être gentil avec les
filles et puis faut pas les toucher
aussi. Il ne faut pas toucher une fille
comment on appelle ceux qui font ça déjà
des viols. Violeur bravo.
Si toi aussi tu as trouvé bravo tu as
gagné un an d'abonnement à pervers
sexuel magazine. Ce mois-ci en cadeau le
bus de B Louis. Goku et Sitoé rentrent
donc chez le grand-père Sparkle. Mais
trop tard, les méchants ont kidnappé le
grand-père et pris la boule à quatre
étoiles. Il s'engage donc une course
poursuite pour le sauver. Mais après
trois explosions, les méchants s'envont
en pensant que Goku et Bulma sont morts
alors qu'en fait ils ont juste sauté 3 m
à côté. Quel plan diabolique. Et là,
malgré le fait que Sang Goku vole plus
vite qu'une voiture sans aucun problème,
il se dit "Non, allons-y plutôt à
d'éléphant. Tu veux un morceau de jambon
?" Non mais sérieusement, je sais qu'il
faut aider un peu le scénard. OK, mais
là c'est complètement con. Grand-père,
je vais te sauver sur les
mains. Allez, on y va. Cependant, leur
promenade est interrompue par Ou qui
visiblement a très envie de se faire une
enfant de 10 ans aujourd'hui. Bien, on
va se marier tous les deux. Je ne peux
pas me marier avec vous, vous êtes troll
la et je suis trop jeune pour me marier.
Je vais m'occuper de toi et tu
deviendras ma femme. Et vous savez,
c'est pour ça qu'il y a certaines choses
qui marcheront toujours mieux en dessin
animé. Mais heureusement, Sang Goku
l'arrête.
Grand-père ne m'avait jamais dit qu'il
existait des personnes aussi noires.
Tellement de blagues possible ici. Sang
Goku bah donc ou en duel qui se
retransforme en humain, sa forme
originelle. Mais finalement, un nouveau
personnage intervient. Un cowboy avec
une mitraillette et une perruche sur
l'épaule. Euh, Yamcha, je suis le plus
méchant de tous. Alors, passez-moi votre
fric si vous tenez à la vie.
Bref, après tous ces combats, les héros
apprennent l'histoire des sep boules du
dragon par la jeune fille qu'ils ont
sauvé de Houang. Tu as dit l'homme
tortue. Oui, c'est ça le vrai de vrai.
Oui. Ah ben ça va, elle est plutôt
détendue quand même. Sachant qu'elle
piquennique avec le mec qui a essayé de
la violer il y a une heure. Donc avant
d'attaquer le roi cornu, c'est lui je
rappelle, pour récupérer sa boule, les
gentilles décident d'aller chercher
l'aide du maître des tortues. Je veux
dire qu'il est plutôt pas mal dans son
rôle pour une fois. Bref, alors je vous
passe les sous-intrigues mais Tortue
génial finit par appeler le nuage
magique et le donne à sang Goku. Et
c'est super, il va enfin pouvoir voler
comme depuis le début du film en fait.
Comme dans le manga, tortue géniale a
une des boules et n'accepte de la donner
que si Bulma lui montre sa culotte.
Alors en échange de la boule, je veux
t'avoir nu. OK, moi je me casse. Allez,
c'est dégoûtant. Vous devriez avoir
Ouais, ce pédophile a raison. Et toi, tu
es un joli lot et je veux t'admirer sans
tes vêtements. Mais pourquoi vous en
rajoutez ? Ça va montrer sa culotte,
c'était mignon, ça suffisait. Pourquoi
vous en faites un truc dégueulasse ? Bon
bref, donc après une scène terriblement
embarrassante pour la dignité des êtres
humains en général, l'intrigue reprend
et il serait temps parce qu'il ne reste
que 20 minutes au film pour tout finir.
Vous savez, les méchants à battre, les
Dragon Ball à réunir, le grand-père à
délivré aussi. C'est vrai que tout le
monde s'en fout de ce mec. Je suis sûr
que Sang Goku va me sauver et qu'il
prépare un plan pour me
délivrer. Et bref, du coup, tout le
reste de l'intrigue va être rusé de
manière absolument hallucinante. Donc
les méchants attaquent l'île de tortu
géniale pour récupérer les Dragon Ball
et font tout péter aussi hein parce que
voilà, les gentiles donc décident
d'attaquer la base ennemie. Explosion,
explosion, explosion. Les deux méchants
secondaires meurent en genre 10
secondes. Le roi cornu menace de tuer le
grand-père de sang Goku s'il ne leur
donne pas la dernière boule. Mais malgré
la menace, Goku et ses amis refusent et
donc du coup qu'il meur grand-père et
ben il leur rend. Voilà.
Donnez-moi les boues. Non. OK. Mais en
fait l'explication est très simple,
c'est que [ __ ] il reste que 5
minutes. Dépêchez-vous, dépêchez-vous.
Donc le roi cornure ramène les
villageois morts à la vie grâce au
vaudou parce que OK mais Sang Goku
réussit à se sauver et à l'aide de
tortue géniale ils font avaler la
dernière bouleau à cornue qui explose
lorsque Shenron apparaît. Je n'exaucerai
qu'un vœu alors est dégueulasse et
victoire le village est ressuscité pile.
On a fini et voilà c'était Dragon Ball
the Magic Begins. Sachez cependant que
je vous ai montré là la version
originale parce que Dragon Ball the
Magic Begin c'est un peu comme Star
Wars. Tu veux dire que c'est un film qui
a fait rêver toute une génération et qui
a marqué un tournoi dans la pop culture
? Ah, j'ai trouvé une autre boule. Non,
je veux dire qu'il y a eu plein
d'éditions de merde avec de la 3D
rajoutée. Ce film est sorti en 91 mais
il a été refait en Ultimate édition en
2007 avec tortue géniale qui a une tête
de tortue, des effets améliorés et
surtout de la [ __ ] de 3D qui défonce.
[Musique]
2007, c'est le meilleur épisode de Code
Loko que j'ai jamais vu. Dragon Ball D R
A G O N B O L.
Vous marquez 50 points et vous mélangez
s'il vous plaît.
Ah, ça y est, je l'ai trouvé. Ça m'en
fait 6 maintenant. Merci monsieur Varo.
Si nous en France, on connaît Dragon
Ball depuis la fin des années 80, sachez
qu'aux États-Unis, ils ont pas eu cette
chance puisque chez eux, Dragon Ball et
Dragon Ball Z ne sont arrivé que en 98,
soit 10 ans après nous. Du coup, début
2000, la Fox décide de racheter les
droits en pleine hype du phénomène
Dragon Ball Z aux États-Unis et en
confie les reennes à James Wong,
notamment connu pour destination finale
1 et 3 et dans le film s'appellera
Dragon Ball. Peu de temps avant la
sortie du film, lorsque les premières
images commencent à faire leurs
apparitions, les gens sont genre dude,
what the fuck ? Et du coup, ben je
suppose que la Fox c'est non mais c'est
pas c'est Dragon Ball évolution en fait,
c'est pas pareil.
Sachez que l'acteur principal a disparu,
que le réalisateur n'a plus jamais
refait de film et que le scénariste
s'est excusé. Alors oui, bon je sais
c'est tiré sur l'ambulance mais là en
même temps l'ambulance la chercher. Un
guerrier du nom de Piccolo surgit
d'au-delà des étoiles et plongea notre
monde autrefois paisible dans les
ténèbres et le chaos. Aidé de son fidèle
disciple Osarou. Voilà. Donc si j'enlève
la durée du générique de la Fox au
début, donc le manga s'est fait [ __ ]
en moins de 25 secondes. Voilà, on peut
y aller. D'ailleurs, techniquement, à ce
moment-là, tu as encore le temps de
changer de salle au cinéma sans avoir
rien loupé des autres films.
La première
règle, c'est qu'il n'y a pas de règle.
Ah, je sens que cette phrase va bien
résumer ce film. On retrouve donc Sang
Goku qui s'entraîne contre le Michel
Galabru chinois, qui perd contre lui et
qui du coup demande à son grand-père de
lui apprendre autre chose, quelque chose
de plus utile que la baston.
Apprends-moi quelque chose d'utile.
Apprends-moi le kamam voler. La maîtrise
du qui ? Comment faire avec les filles ?
Oh, du calme, ça va, fais pas ça, on se
détend. On est qu'à 5 minutes. Après un
conseil sage et avisé. Le l'important
c'est d'avoir foi en ce que tu es toi.
Le grand-père donne donc la boule à
quatre étoiles à Goku et puis là le film
explose.
Oh duc, fais pas ça, prends ça plutôt.
Et donc on voit tout ce que vous avez
toujours eu envie de voir dans un film
Dragon Ball, c'està-dire le scooter de
sang Goku qui se fait écraser devant son
lycée par deux ados pourris et qui ne
veut pas se battre parce que sang Goku
est quelqu'un de très responsable comme
on le sait tous et du coup bah il se
retient de les taper comme le montre ce
jeu d'acteur
excellent. Bref, pendant ce temps-là sur
le Hov, on découvre le méchant du film
en la personne de Piccolo. Piccolo qui
donc récupère les boules de cristal à
l'aide de bon on va l'appeler random
bonas hein vu qu'on connaît pas son nom.
Et après une courte scène, c'est le seul
film qui voulait m'embocher. L'histoire
revient sur Goku dans son école
spécialisée pour adolescents en retard.
Qui provoque une éclipse ? H monsieur
Kingery où il ve une éclipse solaire est
provoquée par le passage de la lune
devant le soleil. C'est bien Jonathan.
Allez on applaudit tous
Jonathan. Tu as gagné un sourire. Bravo.
Évidemment Sang Goku qui n'a rien écouté
répond à côté. Comment nos ancêtres
interprétaitil l'arrivée d'une éclipse ?
Et bien mon grand-père vous dirait
prenez garde de Namec ta gueule juste
ferme ta gueule. Cependant Sang Goku qui
flash sur Chichi réussit à se faire
inviter à une fête et prend avec lui sa
boule de cristal parce que s'il a prend
pas ben le scénario, il sera bien
emmerdé quand les méchants ils vont la
trouver dans moins de 10 minutes
lorsqu'ils vont attaquer le grand-père.
Donc pendant que Sang Goku chope de la
meuf en soirée, Piccolo réussit
surprenamment, personne ne l'avait vu
venir à trouver la maison du grand-père.
Goku revient et trouve son grand-père
mourant qui le renvoie vers Tortue
génial avant de succomber à ses
blessures. Garde toujours la foi en ce
que tu es.
Le lendemain, Goku qui a été rejoint par
Bulma entre-temps qui cherche aussi les
Dragon Ball partent ensemble pour
trouver Tortue géniale qui habite au
milieu d'une [ __ ] de ville géante.
[ __ ] on dirait la maison du vieux
dans là-haut. Goku et Tortu génial se
battent mais ils finissent quand même
par sympathiser. Je suis le maître du
tortue Rochy l'invincible.
OK. Et d'ailleurs au passage, rien à
voir. Mais pourquoi est-ce que dans ce
film tous les persos secondaires sont
asiatique et tous les persos principaux
sont blancs ? Bah enfin bref, donc après
avoir trouvé la Dragon Ball de Tortue
géniale, Dragon Ball qui sont aussi
visiblement des boules à flashback, je
sais pas. Ah, j'ai vu la fin de ma
carrière. Bulma, tortue génial et
sangoku décident donc de partir à la
recherche du mec qui a volé le fond
vert. [ __ ] sérieusement, il y a 30
millions de budget là-dedans. Et
rencontre au passage Yamcha qui est
juste un mec qui s'appelle Yamcha.
Voilà, donc il a aucun pouvoir. Il sait
pas se battre mais il s'appelle Yamcha.
Donc je suppose que les fans seront
contents, non ? Et quand vous mettez des
personnages au moins faites en sorte
qu'il soient utile à l'histoire et qui
ressemblent un peu aussi. Et essayez de
faire semblant de faire des efforts. Au
moins, je veux dire sérieusement, il
tombe dans le seul trouilètres à la
ronde et comme par hasard dedans, il y a
une Dragon Ball. La boule de cristal est
par ici. J'ai trouvé une Dragon Ball
dans mon donut. Et salut crisle. Je suis
chauve. Donc il trouve aussi une autre
boule dans un volcan juste à côté.
Évidemment sur un joli piédestal.
Sérieux, c'est quoi ce monde de RPG ?
Mais dans un rayon de 10 km, il y a un
volcan, une ville, une montagne, un
désert et en plus faut savoir qu'ils ont
que de jours pour trouver tous les
Dragon Ball et qu'ils soient à pied.
[ __ ] mais le monde de Pokémon, il a
plus de cohérence quoi. Bon, alors je
vous passe la manière complètement
conne j'en sais rien vu qu'il prononce
pas son nom, donc on va dire Mister
Popo. On retrouve donc Sang Goku qui
apprend le Kamea. S'il vous plaît, ne
ratez pas ça. S'il vous plaît, ne ratez
pas ça.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Exerce-toi à allumer les torches de la
cour. Nous nous verrons demain matin.
Allumer les lampes.
[Applaudissements]
Pourquoi juste ? Pourquoi le geste du
dessin animé, il est parfait, il est
simple, il est culte, tous les gens de
10 à 30 ans le connaissent. Alors juste
pourquoi ? Qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on vous a fait
? Bon donc après une scène de plus avec
Chichi qui essaie de motiver Sang Goku
en le chauffant. Chichi que bon
maintenant je vais juste me contenter
d'appeler père de Nibar parce que bon à
chaque fois qu'elle apparaît non
seulement elle a des décolletés qui
plongent jusqu'au centre de la terre
mais surtout sa seule utilité au film
c'est d'être le stel s'intéresse de Goku
fait mais par pitié ce personnage mérite
mieux que ça bref donc elle réussi à
motiver Goku qui maîtrise le Kamea oh
ben alors c'est qu' champion mais en
fait surprise random bonas se faisait
passer pour prear afin de récupérer les
boules du dragon oui mais oh désolé mais
me jugez pas si vous avez pas vu le film
donc ben c'est un Goku qui vient de se
faire défoncer par une pauvre arme de
merde manque de mourir. Mais grâce au
Kameameamea qui ne sert pas qu'à allumer
des bougies mais qui fait aussi le café
et bien Goku revit et se dirige vers
Piccolo pour l'affrontement final. Ça
va, il a la tenue orange là comme dans
votre merde de manga là. Vous êtes
content ? Non. Le plan pour enfermer
Piccolo avec le mafuba échou et Piccolo
fait la terrible révélation du film.
Ozaru qui avait détruit le monde il y a
2000 ans était en fait
Goku. C'est ça le sa géant qui a détruit
le monde ? Il fait 2,50. Tu pètes un
pont. Il peut plus passer évidemment
hein. Goku donc fini par retrouver ses
esprits. Ouf ! Le monde est sauvé. Mon
plan est parfait. Je vais conquérir le
monde avec l'aide de Shang Goku. Je veux
pas. Non, c'est pas vrai. C'était la
seule faille. Et après une scène qui est
digne d'un vieux fan film pourri qu'on
trouverait sur YouTube, et bien Piccolo
est vaincu et il se sert des boules pour
ressusciter Tortu génial et son
grand-père, on s'en branle. Allons
plutôt choper de la gonzesse. Et voilà,
fin du film. Et bien, puisque ce film
s'est torché le cul avec mes souvenirs,
et bien moi, je vais me torcher le cul
avec. Il y a une scène post
crédit. Il y a une scène postcit. Il y a
une scène post crédit. Vous croyez qu'à
un moment, ils se sont dit qu'il allait
avoir une suite ? Vous pensez qu'à un
moment, ils se sont dit que les gens
allaient
aimer la nana, elle récupère un mec vert
et elle se pose aucune question. Vert ?
Oh mon dieu, je suis aveugle.
Et ce jeu d'acteur incroyable. Mais
l'acteur là de Piccolo, il a quitté son
corps. Tu peux mettre n'importe quelle
réplique dessus, ça passe. Je voulais
une
tisane, je veux pas aller à l'école.
minutes. Je crois qu'on a touché le fond
de l'océan avec ce film. Et pourtant ce
film, il a encore moins d'excuses que
les autres parce que il y a du budget
derrière. Sachez par ailleurs qu'il
existe un troisème film Dragon Ball dont
je vais parler très rapidement sans
entrer dans les détails parce qu'il est
impossible à trouver en bonne qualité ou
en version traduite. C'est le film
Dragon Ball coréen et c'est dommage
parce que c'est celui qui essaie le plus
de respecter le manga. On retrouve dans
ce film un petit sang Goku qui a enfin
le bon âge, la tenue de la bonne
couleur, la bonne coiffure, une queue de
singe et si on oublie le fait qu'il a
des poils dans le nez. absolument
dégueulasse et je comprends pas
pourquoi. Surtout que après tu vois plus
que ça du coup et bien les événements
suivent bien le déroulement du manga.
Rencontre avec Bulma check. Ramener la
tortue check. Pan, les boules ont
disparu check. Le kidnapping de Bulma
par un
péranodon. Bon ok après il y a des
choses qu'on peut pas faire. Même les
personnages collent parfaitement.
Plume, yamcha, il y a même Chichi avec
exactement la même scène que dans le
manga. Et le Kamea est enfin un kamamea,
c'est pas difficile [ __ ] Et c'était
si bien parti. Qu'est-ce qui vous est
arrivé ? Et bien donc à la fin, on a
envrac des robots géants, des samouraïs
avec des costumes de saen et Pilaf qui
défonce presque Sang Goku en combat mais
heureusement la tortue arrive et
renverse la situation ce qui permet à
Sang Goku et Houong de faire le Kamea
final. C'est quoi ce dérapage ? C'est
comme si le film s'était mis à boire en
plein milieu. Ça va, vous avez vu
combien ça coûte là ? La collection
complète apparît dragon sacré et ex mon
vœu. Et j'exerai ton souhait.
Je voudrais je voudrais m'excuser auprès
d'Arian. Mais [ __ ] j'allais demander
une culotte moi. Non, parce que après
toutes ces merdes sur Dragon Ball, je me
rends compte que finalement le générique
français c'est pas la pire chose qui a
été faite et puis il était pas si mal
finalement. Et puis je pourrais
l'écouter une dernière fois.
Tenu
esté la
fin de ven
je voudrais détruire la terre
[Musique]
exagon la quête finale.
des boules de cristal venu des étoiles.
[Musique]